no me esperaba este vídeo ver muchas
gracias entonces con lo que quiero
iniciar es que todos cerremos los ojos
vamos a hacer dos respiraciones
profundas
bueno
abran sus ojos
la mitad del oxígeno que acaban de
respirar viene de los océanos la segunda
mitad viene de nuestros increíbles
bosques así de conectados estamos con la
naturaleza una naturaleza que está en
peligro
hace no mucho tiempo me di cuenta de que
teníamos que hacer algo al respecto de
que esto no podía estar así muchos de
los que estamos aquí tal vez hemos
escuchado que la temperatura del mundo
se está elevando que nuestros polos se
están derritiendo que nuestras especies
se están extinguiendo y nuestros suelos
erosionándose pero porque a pesar de
saber todo esto parece que nadie está
haciendo nada al respecto
por eso
me pregunte y por qué es que tú no estás
haciendo nada
no sé cómo ni cuándo pero tengo una
pasión impresionante por el cuidado a la
naturaleza
creo que tenemos una conexión muy
importante y tras investigar más y más
al respecto me di cuenta que una de las
soluciones era cambiar nuestros hábitos
esto involucraba que perdiéramos esa
comodidad que tenemos en donde no nos
importa de dónde vienen o a dónde van
los productos que consumimos o qué
impacto pueden tener las acciones que
estamos realizando
para que esto funcionará para que estos
hábitos pudieran cambiarse necesitábamos
hacer que las personas supieran se
informarán de lo que estaba pasando
por esa razón decidí fundar wish una
asociación civil sin fines de lucro que
busca empoderar a la comunidad a través
de la educación y la acción colectiva
porque aunque al principio no estaba
segura de cómo ni de qué iba a ser
estaba segura de que esta situación
ambiental no me gustaba y no me gusta y
tenemos que hacer algo al respecto
por ello me di cuenta también de que no
se podía lograr nada a menos de que
todos nos uniéramos de que si la
comunidad se comportaba como una gran
familia esto que parecía imposible se
podría volver posible
otro de los problemas a los que me
enfrenté y me di cuenta es de que la
información no se está transmitiendo con
la urgencia que se necesita
hace unos meses el panel
intergubernamental de cambio climático
ipcc uno de los organismos de
científicos más importantes del mundo en
cuestión de cambio climático nos
advirtió quedan diez años diez años para
que tomemos acción inmediata o de lo
contrario ya no habrá vuelta atrás
esta es una llamada que puede sonar
desalentadora pero también nos puede
servir para tomar acción para empezar a
actuar porque a pesar de que muchos de
nosotros creamos que las acciones
cotidianas no tienen impacto y que se
nos haga más fácil culpar al gobierno oa
las empresas de lo que está sucediendo
les quiero compartir que nosotros
tenemos el poder también para que esto
cambie
estos organismos claramente tienen su
parte de culpa y su parte de
responsabilidad pero todos nosotros
también
el proyecto draw down es un grupo de un
grupo interdisciplinario que realizó un
ranking de las 100 soluciones más
efectivas para combatir el cambio
climático dentro de las primeras 53 son
acciones que cada uno de nosotros puede
tomar en su vida diaria dentro de ellas
se encuentra el cómo disponemos de los
equipos que se utilizan prepare el aire
acondicionado porque por los químicos
que contienen otra es basar nuestra
dieta en plantas esto es una decisión
que cada uno de nosotros puede tomar así
como el disminuir el desperdicio de
nuestra comida
en esta lista así también se encuentran
otras soluciones de cosas que cada uno
de nosotros puede tomar y también
déjenme les digo que tiene más impacto
que las casas de cada uno de nosotros se
cambie la iluminación por focos led a
que si se cambiara en la industria del
reciclaje dentro de las casas tiene un
mayor impacto que si se hiciera a nivel
industrial
esto es para que todos ustedes vean como
el poder del cambio está en nosotros si
nosotros como comunidad actuamos vamos a
poder hacer que las cosas cambien
y por eso les quiero compartir 4 pasos
para que las cosas sucedan y para que
cada uno de ustedes se pueda convertir
en un agente del cambio en un agente de
cambio que el mundo necesita
el punto número uno es despierta
despierta lo que está pasando sé
consciente abre tus sentidos
infórmate de lo que está sucediendo
el segundo punto que fue uno de los más
difíciles para mí fue creer en es el de
creer en ti mismo me costaba mucho
trabajo creer al principio que algo que
yo pudiera hacer iba a poder cambiar
algo en el mundo es totalmente abrumador
sin embargo se necesita de cada uno de
nosotros cada uno de nosotros tiene un
talento que aportar no importa tu edad
no importa tu ocupación no importa tu
sexo
todos tenemos la opción
cada día tenemos la oportunidad de tomar
las decisiones que impacten y que hagan
un cambio
esto nos lleva al punto número 3 actúa
actúa atrévete a conciencia y haz que
más personas se enteren de lo que está
sucediendo sigue aprendiendo y colabora
lo más importante es el punto número 4
comparte comparte comparte todo lo que
sabes porque ya que lo sabes esta
obligación compartirlo con los demás
hacer que las cosas sucedan ya lo tienes
lo tienes que estar lo tienes que dar a
los demás es nuestro deber
entonces para decirles los cuatro pasos
son despertar estar atentos de lo que
está pasando cree en ti mismo porque tú
sí puedes hacer que las cosas cambien
actúa haz algo al respecto
y 4 comparte más comunidad porque la
comunidad es la que va a hacer que las
cosas sucedan y que este mundo no se
acabe
por eso yo te invito a que hoy que
tienes la información despiertes
ya tienes las bases
actúa
actúa como si tu vida dependiera de eso
porque realmente lo está haciendo muchas
gracias